this video contains spoilers for
everything within the danganronpa
universe except for v3 if you haven't
played v3 than you're safe but be aware
that everything else is fair game
enjoy the video the detective is neither
light nor shadow we represent neither
justice nor evil that is how we uncover
the absolute truth
we stand neutral in all things and to do
that we have to stand separate from the
rest of society it's kind of
old-fashioned and I can't say it's
entirely rational but it's our family
Creed we do what we must to protect it
hello and welcome to danganronpa 101
series it breaks down everyone and
everything in the danganronpa world but
today we are going to be examining the
initially mysterious ultimate detective
kyoko kiri Geary Kyoko Kerri Geary is an
incredibly calm collected and highly
analytical individual who became part of
the seventieth class of hopes Peak
Academy and thus participant of the
killing school life killing game in
regards to her talent as the ultimate
detective this is due to Kyoko coming
from a long line of famous detectives
although it should be noted that her
father Jin Kirikiri had no interest in
pursuing this profession and was thus
expelled from the family
Kyoko went on to be trained in the ways
of the detective by her grandfather for
hito Kira Giri it was so strict that he
did not even allow Kyoko to see her
dying mother and furthermore for hito
even manipulated Kyoko into hating her
own father however as a result Kyoko was
raised in to a phenomenal detective so
much so that at the age of 13 she solved
the serious astronomical observatory
murder case with the help of
sixteen-year-old Huey Sammy Danny
however it wasn't all success for Kyoko
in the early days as her inexperience
did at one stage caused both of her
hands to be burnt and permanently
scarred a trait that she goes to great
lengths to hide by wearing gloves at all
times and information that Kyoko will
only volunteer to people who she
possesses great trust in regardless
Coco's abilities were recognized by the
talent scouts of hopes Peak Academy who
admitted her into the seventieth class
and rather notably it should be said
that her father Jing kirie kirie was the
headmaster of this institution during
her time at the academy she and her
father appeared to have developed some
sort of working relationship as Kyoko
conducted many investigations for him
including an attempt to look into ISA KU
Kamakura and the tragedy of hopes Peak
Academy which was the very first killing
game crafted by Junko Enoshima
and speaking of when Junko did
eventually implement the tragedy that
sent a wave of despair
the world cocoa and the rest of the 70th
class would be sealed within hopes Peak
Academy by gin for their own safety
however Junko had infiltrated the class
erased their memories and forced them to
participate in a more complex killing
game now rather interestingly unlike
other students Kyoko did not even recall
what her ultimate talent was and for
much of this event she was presented as
quite an enigma despite this lack of
knowledge cooker skills as a detective
were not dulled in the slightest and she
proved absolutely essential in the
ensuing investigations as well as
subsequent class trials that would see
the deaths of all but six of the
students of the 78th class however
during this time Kyoko was one of the
more distant students preferring to keep
to herself and being very selective in
regards to her interactions the one
notable relationship she did form was
with the eventual ultimate hope Makoto
naegi as Kyoko greatly admired his
relentless optimism and it is strongly
hinted that the two developed an
attraction towards each other
in fact this bond became so strong that
when Makoto allowed himself to undergo a
failed execution in the fifth trial
Kyoko went on to risk her life to save
him as well as show him her scarred
hands as a sign of trust that the two
had developed ghosts by this time Kyoko
had also finally remembered that her
talent was the ultimate detective and
she and the remaining surviving students
joined forces and went on to defeat
Junko Enoshima thus ending the killing
game and allowing them to escape into
the outside world
shortly afterwards Kyoko joined the
Future Foundation and was eventually
made head of its fourteenth division
with her duties being to protect the
victims of juncos wave of despair as
well spread hope throughout the world in
the form of future foundation activities
but as part of this Kyoko was also
complicit with the efforts of a
classmate Makoto to rehabilitate the
remnants of despair by replacing them
into the near world program however
after this program was infected by a
virus carrying an AI Junko Enoshima
Kyoko along with Makoto and byakuya made
their way into the program to assist the
remnants of despair in defeating the
virus although this action would result
in Makoto being put on trial for treason
for the act of harboring the remnants of
despair and culminating in Kyoko Makoto
and Sue of other key future foundation
members being roped into a final killing
game during this particular killing game
individual restrictions were placed on
the participants with Geass forbidden
action being particularly cruel which
was passed in the forth time limit with
Makoto still being alive and so as it
appeared Kyoko went on to sacrifice
herself in favor of having Mikoto live
on telling him not to give up on hope No
matter what happens and that she would
always be there for him and while Kyoko
did appear to die following the passing
of the fourth time limit this was all
more or less according to plan as just
prior Kyoko had ingested QW the drug
made by one of the other participants of
the game which counted the lethal
effects of the poison injected into her
Yoko would then be revived by me consume
iki one of the remnants of despair that
Kyoko had had a hand in saving and thus
survived the final killing game
following this the Future Foundation
decided to rebuild hopes Peak Academy
with makoto as its new headmaster and it
is heavily implied to Kyoko serves
directly alongside him as vice principal
small fun facts about Kyoko kiri Giri
Kyoko's family named kiri Giri is formed
by kanji that can be read as folk kata
thus directly referencing her detective
lineage and just being a pretty damn
cool name in general Kyoko is one of the
four characters in the series to have
survived to killing games but the others
being her longtime love interest makoto
as well as AoE Asahina and Hajime Hinata
Kyoko is also one of the very rare
characters within the danganronpa
universe whose talent is not unique to
her alone as she shares the title of
ultimate detective with Shuichi Sahara
from danganronpa v3 and finally a truly
useless fact about underwear during her
school days Kyoko wore black briefs with
a ribbon decoration on the side which I
described as being able to quote obscure
her form which is almost certainly some
form of joke about being able to see
shadows on her skirt at various points
in the game but that pretty much does it
for Kyoko Kira Giri if you enjoyed this
video and the content this channel
produces in general then please do
consider donating to the new world
review patreon because the support of
all of your amazing people is what
continues to make this channel possible
and if patreon isn't quite your style
then please do leave this video a like
share or subscribe because it also helps
support this channel any pro
if you'd like to join the fun at any
time then please do head over to my
disco server where a wide array of
shenanigan retakes place on a daily
basis and finally please do comment with
who what or where you'd like to see
featured in the next danganronpa
[Music]
[Music]